[Música]
no lo he podido poner ofrenda los
pueblos aledaños porque se le pone
Ofrenda para que no se enoja pero
ahorita sí de verdad está enojado para
la gente
[Música]
cuenta la leyenda que hubo una persona
que se encontró a a un anciano allá en
la parte alta del volcán y le dijo que
era era el Popocatépetl y que a través
de él iba a comunicarse con toda la
ciudadanía porque él quería que le
festejaran su cumpleaños
el gobierno municipal la secretaría de
cultura del gobierno del Estado también
habíamos organizado ya un evento muy
bonito para celebrar el cumpleaños del
Popocatépetl Pero bueno se canceló
debido a su a su actividad
[Música]